歡迎回到趙花
阿倫說
今天你到底在忙什麼
今天早上看一看盤就關掉了
對
關掉
你不能買你也不能賣
對啊就看一下這行情
真的好慘喔
然後就沒事了
那我問你喔
像因為今天很多人都有傳訊息跟我說
他覺得這個比上次跌2900多點
體感還要爛
那你有這種感覺嗎
我覺得有耶
因為一開始其實很多全職股
除了台積電啦
台積電其實還好
可是很多全職股一開盤
其實就7、8、9%去了
對 那後面中小型個股跟著補碟
最後連CPO這個最近比較強勢的
沙尾盤
也升不住了
所以今天這個盤勢
就真的也只能眼睜睜的看著它這樣子
對 就空手看了
但是今天我們的來賓啊
是
他會覺得
大家真的不要在今天這麼驚慌
就今天對他來說
以他的歷程來說
就一個
可能不是小蛋糕
一個小泡芙
小屑屑
對
因為什麼大風大浪
什麼機構沒待過
沒錯
我們先來歡迎他
就是我们也很崇拜的
新南股神威良哥
嗨 大家好
好 威良哥今天来接受
我们的专访
没错
因为威良哥的资历
其实他待过
我们以前常常跟大家讲
他待过所谓的正期
他待过头信
对 头信
今天也是一个重点
所以很清楚想知道
头信在做什么
然后待头股
是大老师
所以今天的风浪
对你来说
真的叫做一颗小泡芙
对不对
当然你必须要先经历过
因為我其實剛加入股市的時候
剛好那一年真的是史上
非常強勁的大多頭
可能沒有像過去這半年一年這麼強
不過就是非常著名的
網路科技的崛起
1999到2000年
那時候真的買什麼賺什麼
最狂的時候都跟我身邊的朋友說
我要賺的不是%數而是倍數
這句話真的沒有吹牛
因為我那時候最差的時候
大概剩一檔是賺50幾%
是賺50幾%
那是最差的時候
最差的
對 因為其他的全部都是翻倍
是 對
只是後來呢
我覺得經歷過
連續大概半年多的
怎麼買怎麼賺的過程
真的像極了
像今年上半年的故事
真的 好像
後來就會發生一件事情
就是市場開始有點反轉了
不過當你在前面的
半年多的時間是
每逢拉回就買進
每逢大跌就用力加碼的
這樣的一個過程
其實人就會被養成多頭慣性
我常說就是被多頭市場寵壞了
所以當下跌的時候
一開始我們會覺得
這一次跟前面都是一樣的
所以就有錢就繼續加碼
沒錢可能就放任也不管
等到真的跌了一段了
時間也這個蠻明顯的
這個經歷了一段長時間的回檔
然後幅度也慢慢的
越拉越開越跌越深的時候
回頭才看到
我怎麼離上面的高點蠻遠的了
才發現苗頭不對
但是通常那時候大概
其實個股都已經
平均是跌三成到四成
不是跟現在很像嗎
對 通常在三成到四成的時候
也會陷入兩難
這時候到底要不要買
會不會砍大家待一股
對 就會想要等反彈
結果可能沒有等到
像個樣的反彈之後
又下殺破敵
所以其實在網路科技那一波
所謂的泡沫破滅之後
很多科技股
尤其越是主流的科技股
網路股
它其實真的不是腰斬
是跌到腳踝
因為光是大盤指數10393
跌到341
大概算你知道
差不多就是跌了七成
所以經歷過那一次的
震撼教育之後
那我痛力思痛
最主要有兩點修正
第一個我發現就是
所有的空投趨勢
它一定是有機可循
它不會突然降臨
那也不會就是迅速的
就是演變成一個空投趨勢
它一定是慢慢慢慢形成的
所以我們一定可以從一些
基本面的蛛絲馬跡找到線索
那第二件事情
從此我戒掉一個習慣
千萬不要下跌就買
拉回就加碼
那資金一定是要有策略性的
就算想要去抄底一些
認為超跌的便宜股票
也不要一口氣就急著
把子彈全部用盡
好 所以這邊的話
也濃縮有一個座右鳴對不對
買強不買弱
買高賣更高
我也希望可以做到
威良哥這樣子
基本面決定股價的高度
籌碼面來決定股價的速度
這些都在操作裡面
其實說的可能簡單
做起來並不是那麼的容易
其實我覺得這兩句話
可以把它濃縮一點就是
我們大部分的投資人
應該都很相信
股市投資說出來就是買低賣高
不過說實在的話
在我自己投資的
前期跟后期
那个绩效的转捩点
就是当我把买地卖高
这四个字丢到税子机
碎掉之后
我从此开启了另外一扇窗
因为我发现
在这个有效率的市场里面
你不要怕买高
但是重点是
你要掌握的是
它未来有没有成长前景
买高能够让你卖更高
尤其我们绝大部分的人
都不是想在股市里面
当巴菲特的信徒
做价值投资
我们喜欢的是动能交易
我们喜欢的是价差操作
所以买高没关系
重点是要卖更高
但是呢
这个如果你没有
把功夫练好花
一线资格
有时候呢
就会变成是一种盲目的
在最高点才进场被割韭菜
对 所以其实待会儿
我们会去提
怎么样能够买高卖更高
如果讲太久再减掉
所以今天早上
我做了什么事情
我就把我的助理
跟研究团队找来
那我想要呢
把我对现在的行情的看法
从而到而跟他们
再论述一次
那我想听听
大家对我的逻辑的想法是什么
我其实不想要找人来做
同温层取暖
我想听听看
有没有人跟我不一样的看法
那我想要确定一件事情
因为我现在想做的策略
就是以静自动
看起来是不作为
但是这个不作为呢
好像议题两面
有点像是摆烂
不做任何动作
所以我们想要确认是
这是思考理性判断之后的不作为
而不是呢
只是因为被行情压垮了
然後選擇逃避的擺爛
這個時候只要確認
基本面沒有改變的話
我覺得我們就可以
換一個視角去看
很多股票是不是在風暴過後
它真的出現了打折的天天價
因為剛剛蔚良哥有講到一句話
他說空頭如果來襲或是像剛剛講到的有一點溫水煮青蛙對不對每次下跌就覺得再去撿一定會贏它其實有機可循可是這一次你覺得
不會像網路泡沫那樣
而是先定下心來
一定有邏輯論述
所以台股的跌跌不休
投資人該怎麼應對
跟那一次就不一樣了
你會覺得現在很多公司打折
反而是機會
為什麼要這樣想呢
因為大家一定現在
跟你講的一樣
好怕喔
好怕現在根本就空頭成形了
我還沉溺在疊下來
就可以撿的心情裡
其實說出來就是
像跟我們身邊的朋友
或者是比我們更資深的前輩
甚或是在電視機前面才會看到
那些產業大佬們
我們向他們取經
那為什麼呢
因為其實不久之前
台積電法術會
大家印象一定很深刻
所以當大疊的時候
如果你對未來的AI趨勢發展
產業前景
開始有一些疑慮的時候
到底是不是因為
被股價下跌影響的信心
那我覺得就回頭
再把所謂的魏哲家
或者是黃仁勳
他們近期對於產業的看法
我覺得可以重新再複習一次
同樣道理我們也可以把
目前手上套牢的個股
或者是暴跌的個股
它的基本面 它的研究報告
我們再從頭再檢視一次
其實就發現最近
股價真的是跌很深
有些已經出現腰斬
但是絕大部分的個股
都沒有出現
很明顯的基本面被下修
絕大部分都沒有
那甚至在這一兩個月
很多市場雜音傳出來的時候
我們還看到有一些個股
它的基本面其實是被上修的
那再者就是我認為
當然我們要有風險意識
不過呢
最好的風控
應該都是在平常就要做好
用個生活來舉例
如果你有風險的意識
那你想要買保險
應該是在平常就買好
那一旦已經生病了
或是發生了突發的事情的時候
你想要買醫療險或意外險
一來根本可能買不到了
二來就算買得到
我相信那個保費會非常非常的貴
因為你就必須要付出風險溢價
所以像今天早上也有人問我說
覺得可能會下探4000點
現在要不要去放空台紙
起貨來做避險
他說會破4萬點大關對不對
是這個意思
對 就是有沒有可能會破到4萬點
那要不要去買台紙期貨
去放空台紙期貨 做避險
針對這個部分我會覺得
像過去台紙期貨呢
甚至它的正價差
可以拉大到600多點以上
現在已經縮小到100多點
那代表呢
已經有500點左右蒸發掉了
所以現在如果你才想要去
放空台紙期貨
那我不能說絕對沒有效果
但是有可能呢
相對是進場的位置跟價格
已經不是那麼樣的合宜了
這就是操作節奏問題
所以我覺得其實
資產配置風險控管
是平常就要做好的
現在我反而會去做的事情
這個節奏也許跟
一些投資人想不太一樣
我覺得應該是要把
相對抗跌的標的
此時此刻準備陸續換到
超跌跟大跌的標的
比方說我自己平常
就有一些類現金的部位
像是高息低波的ETF
或者是债券ETF
当然本来就已经所剩不多
但是还留下的部位
那本来就是属于资产配置的一环
那这些类现金的资产
我在等的是什么
其实就是这种时候
就是这种长相
大跌的时候我会准备来做买进
那其实事实上不久之前
我在季线这里已经先进了第一批
也就是史上最大跌点那一天
那这个就是我把第一波跟债券
變成現金
然後轉換到市值型
跟主動式的台股ETF
因為我認為
將來要反彈的時候
這些標的它的波動大
它的反彈的力道才會強
只不過進場之後
我們也會停看停一下
因為稍早有聊到
不要跌就買 跌就買
所以當我第一批進場之後
我發現彈不太上去
然後反而這一筆部位
我又有點被小套了
所以我也會先停看停一下
不急着去做第二批的加码
微软哥你什么时候
会做第二批的加码
其实买进就要看讯号
那我认为如果是
以大盘的角度来看的话
当然台币要指贬回升
然后韩国股市费城半导体指数
它也必须要出现一个
强而有力的关键KBOX
比如说带量的长虹
那再来就是
我可能会去看一下
我们先前比较弱势的一些
主流族群
有没有开始出现
融资清干净之后的
率先直跌反彈
是 所以今天的跌跌不休
在基本面上面
因為外資或是內資
其實都沒有出現明顯什麼
下修 EPS 什麼的
所以基本面應該是真的問題不大
現在考驗的就是籌碼面
什麼時候恢復歸對對不對
好 所以第二筆的加碼要等市場質問
然後所以這邊的話
剛剛提到了外資最近
有微幅條件
例如國劇 旺系 台光店 台達店
微服調降他們的目標價
我們要擔心嗎
其實外資真的是很搶戲
因為外資的報告往往都是
媒體報導跟市場一般投資人
大家會去追逐的重點
不過其實一篇報告
不能說完全把它當聖經一樣膜拜
但也不要把它當垃圾
或者說好像是一個陰謀
直接就丟到垃圾桶
資源回收了
其實我覺得還是要從
四個面向客觀來看
第一件事情
剛剛提到目標價
最簡單來看
目標價怎麼來
就是預估了EPS乘上本地比
那通常大家拿到報告
大概就是迫不及待
先找到目標價在哪裡
只看目標價
左上角
就把它記住了
但是我通常問投資人說
你知不知道
聯發科的最高目標價
只到一萬元
對 賣格里
一萬元
那你知不知道
那聯發科預估EPS呢
可能大部分人就不記得了
為什麼就表示說
大家只去記目標價
但事實上
目標價只是最後一個數字的參考
那關鍵還是來自於
預估EPS跟本益品
那尤其重點是EPS
那你要知道就是
它的EPS是不是符合
比如說下半年比上半年好
那明年會比今年好
這個趨勢才是重點
那更進步來講
如果那些原文報告
AI有幫你翻譯好
你願意讀下去的話
其實要看清楚是
它對於整個產業的預估它對於整個量產的進度或者它對於它未來的產能擴增的計畫這些相關的基本面的細節它最後才會向拼圖一塊一塊的拼起來
那個所謂的目標價
好 我記得林發科高盛吧
有說2028年要賺到EPS 400元
這個我們也好難判斷
因為現在就賺六七十塊而已
對 所以這個我們就直接來看
第四個關鍵就是要跟大家講
根據兩年後的獲利
來預估的目標價
你絕對不要太迷信
兩年後
那現在已經算
2026的下半年了
對 所以我覺得
如果是看到
2028的上半年以前
還可以接受
那當然2027的參考價值
可信度絕對是更高的
因為現在確實
應該要去反映
明年的獲利了
但是直接一口氣
已經拿望遠鏡
去看到2028
甚至2029
老實說
我覺得就是
看看就好
为什么呢
大家试想
任何一家上市柜的公司
你问老板两年后猜测
他也编不出来
那再来就是呢
因为通常主流热门股
它不会只有一家法人出报告
所以一定有
可能很多家的法人机构
那这个时候
大家真的不要呢
只看你想看
或只记你想记的
目标价最高的或最低的
远远脱离市场公司
我会建议一律先忽略
你抓就是呢
所谓我们讲大数法则
比较多数专业法人
大家不管是对EPS的共识
或对于目标价的共识
我觉得参考度会更高
那通常特别高跟特别低的
可能真的有时候就是
语不惊人 死不休
或其他的目的了
那再来就是
如果有发现说
目标价被调高了
可是EPS没有明显的调高
甚至是完全没有做任何调整
那这个有可能就是属于一种
研究員的formal情緒
研究員也是人
人就有情緒
那它的formal情緒是什麼呢
它怎麼調整
既然EPS沒動
那顯然就是動本益比
把本益比調高
那本益比這東西
本來就帶有主觀
到底要給30倍
還是31倍
還是35倍
其實這個其實有時候
研究員
因為畢竟呢
他上一次的報告
有沒有呢
到達他的目標價
那這個會列為
他們的KPI
所以他就會不斷的
不斷去做一個目標價的調整
接著我們在看這些報告的時候
怎麼運用它
比方說在6月中旬的時候
尤其在17號到29號這一段期間
南電就是出現多家法人
密集都在同步上修
那個時候這些券商
把目標價調高之後
到底有沒有引動市場買盤
有的
因為就在那一段期間
不僅是外資買
本土的投信也買
兩大法人都同步站在買方
再加上就是說
我們按照剛剛的邏輯
我们找出比较符合
市场共识的目标价
其实五大法人的目标价
平均来看是1275元
如果用中位数来排列
也是1275元
所以假设我们就搭配K线
这边刚好整理过后
然后出现了带量的红K
所以这一根6月23号的
突破的K棒
它的高点就是945元
假设我们就用了
当天最高点进场
通常我们会去做一个盘算
就是报酬风险比
是不是大于三倍
如果超过三倍
我觉得这会是一笔
值得交易的投资
那潜在获利空间
大概就是35%
那下档我们就以
当天进场的这一根
关键K棒的低点
当作防守点867
所以如果真的跌破
那我就停损
那下档的风险8%以内
所以它的报酬风险比
这样一除就是4.38倍
那其实已经很明显超过三倍
所以我觉得这个就会是一笔
可以考虑进场的交易
好 大家要學起來
雖然今天的氣氛不是太好
但是一旦之後恢復上行的時候
這就是非常有用的參考方式
然後剛剛也有提到
這個報酬率也許比勝率更重要
這個有的
這可以討論很久
到底是要高勝率還是高報酬率
絕對是要報酬率
兩位是一樣想法嗎
是的
我跟兩個想法不一樣
我都覺得好像要高勝率
賺少一點沒關係
因為以棒球比賽來講
打安打數比較多的
最後不一定是贏家
是計分板上得分比較多的隊伍
他才會是贏家
得分就是報酬率
因為你有可能只打一隻安打
一隻滿貫全雷打
滿貫全雷打 沒錯
兩位做動能的
原來想法是一致的
沒錯 謝位兩位
跟隨 跟隨
雖然今天綠燈比較多
可是位兩位反而來教我們
如果今天又恢復到多頭上行
上行
有很多的股票
开始出现涨停板了
因为你在等这个嘛
你现在把现金换出来
就是为了等这件事嘛
那我们要怎么样找到
对的操作心法
因为往往一反弹
也可能会刷一排红灯
其实所有的标股
不管是你曾经参与过
或者是呢
只是以前有听闻过的
我希望大家
在行情震荡的时候
都回头去看看做个功课
你会发现一件事情
所有的标股
它在启动表态的第一天
99%都是漲停板
都是漲停板標籤
所以漲停板就是標股的起手式
不過邏輯很重要
漲停的股票
後面不一定變標股
有些它就是只有一日或一日半的行情
但是每一個能夠波段大漲
漲五成八成甚至翻倍的
它的前面開始的第一天
99%都是漲停
所以我們一定要先好好研究
同樣是買漲停
那后面谁比较有机会
变成是拨断标股
这就是我的闯红灯心法
所以不要认为涨停不能买
如果后面有十根
第一根你要好好把握
第二根你也要认真研究
第三根以后才要开始稍微停看厅
那基本上第一件事情很重要
有族群性的是最好的
第二个其实买涨停就是要找起涨点
它不是要让你买在低点
要跳脱这个迷失
第一点不重要
那再来特别重要的是
同樣是今天漲停班的股票
那我會按照呢
漲停的時間先後
分成早盤 盤中跟尾盤
那我定義呢
9點半以前是早盤
1點以後是尾盤
介於這中間都是盤中漲停
那優先選擇的
最好的選擇就是漲停
為什麼
大家想想看喔
如果今天有碰到漲停
結果
邁阿亞排山倒海而來
被敲開了
最後守不住了
那今天收盤
要嘛呢變成一個流長長上一線很醜的K棒要嘛甚至變成開高走低的黑K這種形態真正做順勢交易的人都不喜歡
所以如果你
九點就把它拉到漲停去
你一定要讓它
鎖住漲停
那接下來四個多小時
所有的賣壓 賣單
我照單全收
所以這樣的一個阻力
它的心態是非常積極
而且它的財力跟手臂
是很粗的
那再來我認為就是
看位阶跟形态
底部发动的
当然是最好的
其次呢
因为当然一档
长多的标股
中间一定会有休息
跟换手整理
所以中继整理完的
是给你第二次
去研究它
切入它的机会
那当然呢
已经走到相对高档
才做喷出的
反而要小心
高档力竭
这时候的高档
你可能配合
是不是呢
利多进出
或者说呢
技术面的指标
它是不是KD的
这个日线周线
全部都在高档了
那這個時候反而要小心
好 我們就用實際的例子
來幫大家看對不對
好 國際前面真的就是
所謂的闖紅燈概念
後面就闖綠燈概念
那接下來什麼時候可以呢
去掌握它的反彈
或者說逢低加碼
我覺得就看
什麼時候它能夠再次的亮紅燈
亮紅燈
不過呢 我想見往之來
我們可以先看就知道
你看在左邊
這邊一開始就是底部的漲停
那這裡呢 爆大量之後
接著隔一天又漲停
去越过大量高点
换手后整个涨停
这里短暂做拉回之后
又出现了中继整理之后的
喷出涨停
然后又连续的涨停
但是到了这里之后
就高档喷出涨停
如果以这个高档喷出的涨停
跟过去相比
除了当然
技术面的指标已经在高点之外
大家会发现
前面所有的涨停
它出现之后
那个低点从来没被跌破
涨停的低点都没有跌破过
但是这里
这一根高档喷出涨停之后
当然当下我们不知道
是不是結束了
隔天還創了一個新高
但是SOHK
再隔一天的時候
這個低點就破了漲停低點了
慣性確實改變了
那剛剛有特別提到投信
因為微良哥也帶過投信
可是投信
我們現在覺得怪怪的
他們也是一個套牢的狀態
可是可能我們投資人
又一直加碼投信的ETF
所以他們好像不得不買
有沒有問題呢
其實如果以投信來說
當然最重要還是在於
基本面趨勢的研究跟掌握
所以一般來說
如果基本面它很篤定
很有把握的話
它確實不一定說
每一檔個股跌了兩成
它就會去做停損
只要有寫報告的依據的話
那它可以去捍衛它的持股
所以我想最近很多人想知道說
像國劇981A到現在為止
都沒有賣 是怎麼回事
那我個人推敲
應該比較可能就是
他认为被动元件
尤其是像龙头国具
因为MLCC的涨价是货真价实
那营收毛利也确实都有向上提升
只是说可能在操作
有时候毕竟经理人
也不是每两个股
那节奏都完美
高点如果没有跑
但是这波下沙的又急又快
那可能他认为跌到这里
也没有必要进步追砍
所以我才会提到
接下来如果真的整个被动元件
资金有回容
然后流动性变好
开始做反弹的时候
我觉得啦
比方说谈了两层三层之后
那个位阶跟时间点
可能才是真正关键
因为那个时候
有可能投信经营人
才会有进步的动作
那当然这一段期间
我觉得投信当然还是持续有
在台股去做一些
逢低进场的布局
那连续买超的个股也不少
那特别就是
我以这个买超金额来做观察
7月份到现在为止
其实像南亚 台积电 南电等等
这些个股呢
他们真的都是砸了两三百亿
持续来做加码
所以我觉得当这一波
如果慢慢的稳定之后
大家想要搭个投信顺风车的话
你可以去找寻投信真的是重仓布局
而且现在股价可能因为
无差别下沙
它暂时跌破了投信的成本
我们可以去留意这些个股
至少代表这些公司
如果你对它所处的产业
或它的财报看不太懂
投信一定比大家懂
有研究过
基本面至少没有太大的问题
那接下來就是看什麼時候
在操作的點位上
是比較適合介入
好 所以我們這邊有來舉例子
像星星
不過這個真的好難操作
不是漲停就是跌停
因為最近的波動真的太大了
但投信對它是不離不棄的
對 那基本上已經
就是跌到投信的成本下
而且還差了有一段了
所以我覺得是將來
除非真的是投信
將來反彈上去
它想要做減碼或停損
否則來看的話
我覺得現在你絕對是應該
要偏向站在買方來做觀察
那我認為
既然它都已經所謂的
破月線季線了
投信都還是站在買方
顯然真的是在看好
接下來的漲價的動能
會浮現在財報當中
那我覺得股價到目前為止
因為都沒有一個
代量的長紅K出現
對 所以基本上我覺得
這個會是空手的朋友
你要先等待的第一個訊號
那第二個訊號來講的話
如果能夠站上五六均線
而且配合五六均線往上
這會是第二個訊號
那第三个讯号
我会去观察就是
月线跟季线重新集结之后
两条线都泛样往上
所以换句话说
如果真的要切入的投资朋友
我觉得至少要把资金
在这个时候再拆成三笔
分批进场
不要一次认为最低点到了
我就想要O in
那茂莲的状况
我觉得会再好一些
因为它是先跌
然后也跌很深
但是也因为有酝酿了
前面一段的打底
现在反而是
月线已经开始往上
那季线还在往下
不過這兩條線
應該不久之後
就會靠攏在一起了
那現在來看的話
因為今天也稍微有一點出量
然後來挑戰季線
所以慢慢來看的話
如果季線確認也能夠
這個斜率轉折往上
站上所有均線
其實是指日可待的
那相對因為它已經是地位階
投信也都集中在
最近才開始買超
那加上因為有公告了
六月份的EPS
單月大賺了六塊以上
所以我想算起來
本益比也不高
那這種個股
大家也可以去做
留意
好 今天也很谢谢威良哥
就是真的要分辨每一次
古灾到底后面延续的是什么
现在真的支撑我们的信仰
就是基本面业
要不然从形态来看
因为像你喜欢看形态
应该好多形态都走得失控吧
蛮辛苦的
只能说蛮辛苦的
所以一方面相信大人
对不对 相信投信
一方面的话
我们也近代所谓的均线
他们可能要做好手码